hey guys I'm Greg I'm John welcome to
another episode of how it could work how
it could work is where we take ideas
where people are speculating reboot
ideas remakes sequels crossovers today
it's Friday the 13th
so we're gonna do Friday the 13th and
people have been talking about doing a
remake for a long time now yes another
troubled forgotten another remake so
we're going to give our idea or in
remake yeah no comfort no found women's
but this remake idea just to give you
guys a heads up this is solely like how
we would just want to see it not in
terms of like little pitch it in a way
where a studio could pick it yeah this
isn't the only way it could be done this
is just this is the Greg and John yeah
what we think if we they gave it to us
here's what we would do exactly here
exact rule movie in the week of May so
yeah we have a concept that we came up
with let's hop into it so before we go
into like the setup of our plot here one
thing that we were talking about and
John really brought up was that we want
to take it back to where Jason's a
boogie man you had a great point of
saying how he was like the pretty became
like the protagonist yeah around the
runs of franchise he's the antagonist of
each movie but he's the protagonist as a
series by the end of it because he's the
only guy we see every time bringing it
back to was it was the vibe where you
don't see Jason all the [ __ ] time he
is kind of it's more like a spooky could
be supernatural who knows makes Jason
like a boogeyman and also takes some of
the themes from these movies play with
them in a different way because like
every Jason movie involves you know up
you know you reckless young people
having sex in the woods and so we
thought we would take this to make the
story a little bit more personal and use
sort of a sexual anxiety to kind of
motivate some of this and create actual
characters yeah that you know we could
care for that way when killing starts
happening you know it's more the danger
and the stakes are really rate yeah we
don't want another vacuum where it's
just like I you know kind of 2d people
come to this camp and get killed yeah
exactly exactly because we've done that
so many times now set up a bit it takes
place in the 1980s again it's a
moderately average small town takes
place in New Jersey
you know small but right before the
summer there's a mall there's a movie
theater if the suburbs type of town
where there's like enough stuff to do
but if you really want to do anything
interesting you have to drive half an
hour into town you know or into the city
our main character is this guy named
Kevin Kevin is the junior in high school
Kevin is like he's a sweet timid
creative outdoorsy quiet type of nerd
basically the sponge for information he
lives with his father who works for the
Historical Society
so he's heard the legend of campers the
lake or you know aka know now Camp blood
because of the events that happened back
then yeah we don't want it his dad give
this feel so many times I know the end
and many others but you know it gives
him a nice you know sort of working
knowledge of the story yeah and Kevin
he's really close with his dad because
Kevin's an only child Kevin's mom passed
away a few years ago actually but anyway
at school though the main female
character of this story is a girl named
Becky Becky is this girl that Kevin has
a crush on she's reasonably popular too
kind woman good head on her shoulders
she doesn't have trouble keeping up with
studies but she like also knows the
value of having a good time
yeah she's popular but she's not like
snooty or anything she just you know
occupies the upper crust she's got big
dreams of leaving so she's worked her
way up to the top of the high school
chain and once that done she's blowing
this popsicle stay exactly and Becky
her character's dating the main male
supporting character which is a dude
named Dylan Dylan he's like a swimmer
how food-chain yeah he is he's one of
the star swimmers in Ozzy starter but he
is a pretty good swimmer he's
competitive and you know kind of
self-centered prone to indulging in that
competitive spirit you know probably has
a lot of pressure riding on him and
naturally he doesn't treat Kevin very
kindly at all because he can tell from a
mile away that he's crushing on his
chick you know yeah so why would he and
basically in class one day Kevin
overhears Dylan and Becky talking with
their small circle of friends about this
birthday true if you want to take but
don't dad is a contractor who's like
just bought a patch of land on a steel
so they got carte blanche to use the
place until they break ground nobody
gonna be a nobody going to be there so
later on that night
kevin has dinner with his dad as a dad
is like one of the there's probably the
only one he can really confide in the
only one I could really talk to and have
an open conversation with yeah he tells
his father about this trip that he heard
that Becky is going to be taking the dad
asks like Oh where's that land Kevin
doesn't know but in passing like after
they're done having dinner he mentions
that oh did you hear that they're gonna
close down did he attempt you know dad
doesn't let on it's exactly what's
happening but he does have an idea of
like they're going to tear it down it's
already closed but they're going to tear
down what happens then next is that
night when Kevin finally goes to sleep
he has a dream about the camp incident
about the story of Jason about this
mentally disabled deformed body
kid eeeyah was bullied a lot drowning in
the lake at Camp Crystal Lake he has
this sort of surreal dream partly you
know flashes from the actual legend you
know as it's just come up it on his mind
again but also you know that the general
anxieties of ridicule and sort of body
discomfort that come with being a knight
exactly so this so the next day it's
hired like Kevin eel or Chasseur school
the next day he's tired he didn't really
sleep well last night so he spends most
of the day just kind of nodding off and
doodling in classes and stuff and he
begins just in his doodles he starts to
draw these images from his dream and and
he writes down the words Jason lives
just kind of absent mindedly and the
image he draws of Jason isn't Co the
same hockey mask
you know he's not telepathic it's just
it's an impression of Jason as told
through the stories his imagining of the
sickly you know deformed boy so later on
that day you see still in Becky they're
a small group of friends or having lunch
Dillon Lee isn't able to use the
bathroom which gives Kevin this
opportunity to approach Becky because he
doesn't ever try to talk to Becky
especially of Dylan's around so quietly
and reserved though there's this like
awkward interaction he manages to like
tell the group of primarily he's
directing it at Becky that he doesn't
have a good feeling about them going to
Crystal Lake for the weekend ya can't
really specify why because he's not even
entirely sure why he's having this
feeling because this dreams is kind of
haunting him that he's thought about but
in this moment when he's trying to warn
Becky out of concern Dillon returns
without Kevin noticing the hope shake
Dylan's here and they jack the notebook
that Kevin was due
don't starts making fun of him for this
like creepy image that he has on the
paper so yeah feeling threatened by
Kevin he just to insult him he tears out
the page crumpled it up and throws it on
the ground bell rings they all go they
all have to go back to what they're
doing but before they leave Becky grabs
the paper and kind of looks at it but
then puts it in her backpack and at some
point earlier during this day he does
get verification that Crystal Lake is in
fact where they're going like he does
over here something let's be doing our
whole act once to get up right there
that's all that's our act once that
totally is all making sense still
perfecting how to do this so then we
would break an act to Dylan Becky the
gang is the other characters the game we
don't really know their names you have
to work whatever not really good not a
good decision to treatment yeah the
important characters yeah they're having
a great time at Camp Crystal Lake einde
of like what we'd expect from the Friday
the 13th movie a like oh they're going
to Camp Crystal Lake they're having fun
they're having a blast later on that
night they're sitting around they built
a campfire and then kevin is brought up
in conversation clearly at this point
though becky is still kind of spooked by
Kevin's warning about them not going to
the camp and she starts asking like why
do you think he was saying all those
things and then one of the other guys in
the group do that we're going to
temporarily call Brian for now he shares
like the urban legend tale of the boy
named Jason who drowned in the water and
now haunt this campsite he gives us the
full rundown of the myth for the moon
yeah so we're like trying to build up
Jason as this myth right now instead of
just you know like yeah boys go to the
beta go to the camp and they start
getting killed and see how the myth
applies to all the different characters
because there are lots of just small
town ghost stories and then that's kind
of how we want to approach the setup of
this and revisiting it makes Becky even
more freaked out by everything
Becky really wants to leave she's
getting more spooked the longer the tale
goes on the rest of the gang is really
taking it seriously they're making fun
of Kevin they're making fun of Becky now
a little bit you know because you know
you're just afraid of a little ghost
story yeah go story about a boy who died
over 20 years ago at this camp yeah so
at that that night though when the group
divides into cabins we kind of want to
have a like a like a deceitful kind of
scene where Dillon's kind of drunk he
forces Becky into like having sex yeah
where Dillon is just very very extremely
rough but the entire time we can see
that Becky is
paranoid and fearful you can see that
he's feeling like someone's possibly
watching them yeah but no one actually
appears in this moment but the whole
time you keep thinking those someone
going to show up is yes we're like oh
the kids are going to die while they're
bucking this is where we can we can
really play with this sort of ghostly
you know spectral elements because there
can there so many potentials for strange
noises or you know tricks to the eye
yeah we can get creative with you know
all the kind of creepy little things
that people are hearing and thinking
just because the Nugget should've been
planted in their mind by X Tory so that
happens on a Friday Saturday the next
day they return home on a Sunday the
game returns home safely
Dillons like feed Becky had nothing to
worry about we're all fine we're all
alive and then this is when you know
we're breaking into her fun [ __ ] fun
scary stuff really begin to take place
the boy Brian who shared the story about
Jason he doesn't attend school the next
day and then later on we have a scene
where one of the girls and Dillon in
Becky's group is like I have those I was
like oh being thought she feels like
something's watching her at her home and
then she gets annihilated but we don't
fully see how she gets killed but when
we like when people discover the body
it's like really [ __ ] just torn apart
yet this is the time where we get to
have some really cool okay yes so
instead of them all going to campus the
leg and they all die it's kind of like
you step in a camp Crystal Lake and you
do stuff then if you leave it's like you
you're taking the curse with you this
time yeah I'm giving that vibe kind of
giving that present we kind of wanted to
borrow from some of the eighties revival
stuff and and I almost took a little
inspiration from it follows and things
like that word is like you cross a
specific barrier and now you have this
sort of curse upon you exactly at least
in a vague way so the news of the girl's
death in the group it spreads throughout
the school in grief with everyone dylan
finds kevin and accuses him of murdering
his friends as one of the friends is
still missing the other friend is you
know the girl has been discovered dead
dylan recounts you know kevin warning
them not to go on the trip but now he
kind of believes that was a death threat
and not a you know like a concern yeah
maybe this is you know this kid's kind
of quiet he's kind of strange that
outburst in the cafeteria with dylan
before the job is a little suspect and
Dylan can kind of use that to his yeah
so using his influence Dylan now has
everyone in the school practically
believing that Kevin is got Hillary's
yeah a little bit later on Kevin does
find a Becky alone at one moment and try
and he he tries to tell her like it
wasn't him that did it it wasn't him and
Becky looks at him and I imagine I
imagine a sort of scene and nobody ever
to do it God was but I imagine a scene
where and somehow he's trying to say who
he thinks it is what he can't say
because he thinks it sounds ridiculous
yeah exactly kind of fills in the blank
and said like yeah I think it was Jason
you know like she's starting to think
now maybe it was Jason the midpoint of
this film with like while Kevin's at
school he gets the cops call him in he
gets arrested in questioned by the
authorities
so while Kevin's are the police Becky
learns about Jason Voorhees his mother
Pamela Voorhees and that Pamela is still
alive and she's actually a resident in
the small town that they live in but
she's kind of anti-social she doesn't
really talk with too many people yes to
herself she stays in home a lot she's
sort of the only person who was there
around that time she's the only person
left from the time you know or who has
an intimate knowledge of any kind I
don't know if we necessarily know that
she's Jason's mom right now feel like
that could kind of be a cool reveal for
their conversation but she's the only
person to talk to about this basically
he's not gonna give you the same yet you
know Becky decides after school that
she's going to secretly you know not
telling her friends we're gonna try to
find Hamill and pay her a visit yeah so
Becky gets invited into her home they
end up having a sit-down conversation we
see Pamela like was really sweet really
kind lady but she finds it out or she
brings it up about Jason's death and she
tells her about Jason and her experience
with that incident when she lost her son
and Becky brings up you know the spooky
ghost stories that I've been spread
about her son seeing if she's like heard
about it yeah and Pamela is aware of
these stories what excuses them as just
nothing but a school yeah these are just
you know people love to distort the
truth for for a good fright during the
scene at some point it does Becky does
let out that they went to the camp and
you know Pamela makes a note of that and
then eventually when Kevin does get back
in school the stories become worse of
worse the initial warning out of concern
that he's told Becky has now been spread
to have been like a straightforward
threat that he gave like yeah really
twisting the whole story as at the
game of telephone takes place throughout
school and now that's missing I'm not
good for Kevin exactly
Kevin is more isolated than ever at this
point
Becky however decides one day to sit
with Kevin and tell him that she doesn't
believe that Kevin did it she just
firmly believe that Kevin is not
responsible and she explains that the
night that she went to the camp she
could feel something was at the camp
some kind of yes she's not sure but yeah
there was some kind of Nestle malevolent
this is it
Maleficent starring Angelina Jolie was
playing she's not sure what but she
could feel some presence of another was
there the time passes Becky loses
respect from other students including
her friends for befriended Kevin yeah
they they kind of start to lump her in
as a freak too or like she's going crazy
because yeah these things that have
happened and then one night Becky goes
home to Kevin's place this they're
hanging out they're bonding they're
having real conversations I imagine like
they have that intimate moment where
Kevin opens up about like what it was
like to lose his mom yeah so we're
really getting to see them at a more
vulnerable place and they're really
having a bonding moment there's a knock
on the door
Kevin opens the door gets knocked out
because it's [ __ ] Dylan yeah
because not he knocking knocks coming to
the ground Dylan comes barging and he's
trying to like drag Becky out of the
house because he's concerned her like
he's angry but he's concerned you know
and it's this going you really does not
like and or trust or anything Kevin
anything Kevin related right that he
takes her stand and says that she's
going to stay yeah that she believes
Kevin didn't do it yada-yada-yada
they're having this in their app you
don't know what you're dealing like shut
up or yeah they're having this major
[ __ ] argument things start to slowly
simmer down suddenly Jason Vorhees
Bernadin [ __ ] appears Jason Voorhees
now we see him like this is close to the
finale but it's not exactly the finality
it's a little bit like happening when I
grew through the door rips through the
jaws erotic explodes into shards of wood
anything Jason that we know yeah giant
burly husky dude thank God like the kind
of guy who's big and imposing but also
looks like he might just have been
living in the woods for a while like
it's it's kind of hard to say exactly
what the nature of Jason is he's just
[ __ ] scary yeah exactly right when
Jason Burstyn he immediately killed
dillan in front of you haven't and becky
they both witnesses like horrific death
instantly this leads into an escape
seemed leo classic horror escape scene
where they're trying to get away from
the killer you know running up the
stairs they can't get out and then I
imagine a moment that we see where you
know Kevin's trying to protect Becky
maybe trying to close a door you just
decide to stand up to this [ __ ]
monster he basically buys her enough
time to get up yeah but then Jason and
Jason knocks him out but doesn't kill
him you know we've seen that Jason's
kind of let them live CJ do one of those
things where it's like you do a POV
where you can kind of see Jason standing
over him and you're like oh this a bad
time to blackout but I'm going to make
it but then we wake that guy yeah so for
whatever reason Jason leaves Kevin you
see Jason you oh [ __ ] this is bad
Kevin's blacking out and then we
immediately come to and dad's waking
omocha we have no idea it's like we
passed out on Jason and now it's dead we
cut back to Becky she's in a bad way
she's been wandering for a little while
she's kind of losing it was she trying
to get to the police station and sort of
on her way there she passes mrs.
Voorhees place at which point mrs.
Voorhees comes out to check on her and
at first that's a comforting thing at
first it's like oh you might know
something here we can go to the police
together and and the second that comes
up mrs. bore he starts to shift and get
a little more crazy and it becomes clear
that she's not necessarily a comforting
presence and she kidnaps Becky and takes
her off somewhere ostensibly to the
woods which immediately you know when we
come back to Kevin immediately his first
thought is I got a [ __ ] finds I gotta
find that you yeah I don't know if she
is or not there could be cops there and
everything it was like talking to them
and Tara gating that Terrier situation
taking out Dylan's body and everything
but they can tell like this definitely
isn't Kevin so Kevin's name is clear
because there's no way that kept because
Kevin was already knocked out I could
see by all the damage there's no way
that's a hot highschool kid could have
done have done any of this you know yeah
Kevin's trying to find Becky no one has
seen her no one's heard from her Kevin
gets a hunch that maybe he's maybe she's
been taking a crystal way if this was
Jason who came in you know like he
starts getting the idea that maybe okay
this is maybe this is a real man now now
that he saw
form kid ghost this is a big giant and
Becky is the only one left of the kids
who went up that weekend yeah Kevin
takes his dad's car decides to drive at
Crystal Lake and then we cut to in
Crystal Lake
you know she's being to being pushed
through the woods maybe Pamela has a gun
or something you know I whole dragon I
mean yeah aiming it at Becky and as
she's like dragging Becky to the Crystal
to Crystal Lake specifically to the
water
you know she's explaining that this is
her son's birthday and that she believes
Jason is alive and that she she's
bringing Becky to her son as a gift for
his birthday because this is her chance
for her to see Jason Voorhees again this
is Pamela's chance to see her son one
more time but before Jason can show up
we're thinking of some way work Kevin
arrives it allows for Pamela to get
distracted alarm for Becky like grab an
item or rock or something basically
build a tent situation on the fact that
it's the three of them and mrs. Voorhees
has more leverage but they too have the
numbers together and yet ride that sort
of tension until Becky can clocker Becky
Koster out hits her one more and I
pretty much knew I heard that range you
left that ring I guess that cathartic he
like he's like covered in blood she can
you can see the trauma she has from
killing this woman yeah but think
Kevin's like okay we got to go so he
grabs Becky they start running away to
immediately bump into Jason where I
imagine Jason just [ __ ] killed Becky
right away
yeah he just slaughters Becky right away
Kevin just fall to the ground like
awaiting his fate now assuming he's
gonna die next
and then Jason looks at him but then
just walks away letting Kevin live I
don't really have anything after that
dancing right we're not getting paid to
do this the Rockies a to write a hole
doing this literally is our basic beat
sheet in common there's just sort of
that rough first draft of a treatment
and we did talk about the onions like I
think it might be cool because you know
the final girl is such an ingrained
thing in you know slasher movie you know
rules in the slasher movie rulebook and
this might be just a cool opportunity to
do a final boy or something like that
just change it up a little bit and kind
of give you something you weren't expect
as much and a little bit as a mystery as
to why he doesn't ever kill Kevin yeah
you know kind of maybe sequel leading a
franchise it's a little bit yeah boy
words like why won't he kill Kevin what
is it about Kevin that he just lets him
live or I was like is Jason more
specific about who he decides to kill
yeah and once you visit his camp and you
can sort of ride off those those
metaphors and things like that because
part of the point of the second action
when they go to the camp is like if
Jason's there he can clearly observe
that these are kind of like the people
who are responsible for at least what we
know about that legend you know yeah the
negligent sort of counselors who came up
to canoodle and they've come to displace
like the scene of a gruesome gasps of
art part of why Jason died was because
the counselors were watching the kids -
the counselors are having sex with each
other just the fact that Becky was
[ __ ] Dylan at the time it be enough
to prom Jason to be to you know decide
okay she's part of his hit list now -
yeah and you know like Kevin wasn't
there for any of that and Kevin for all
intents and purposes is a pretty
innocent character I think the only
reason necessarily that Becky has to die
is just because of a mama for he yeah
you know well yeah actually Jason
jatin sees that Becky killed Pamela
Ward's yeah there you go all lots a
little speculation splash ridden concept
that we have it yeah sure if we went
over this again we would change you know
we would tweak it we were drafted a yeah
like this seems like a cool foundation
for like hey you want to reboot Friday
13th like 80s nostalgia is all the rage
you could shoot it with a very you know
distinct and deliberate visual style we
use touchstones again like it follows
and stuff like that give it that really
distinct and deliberate you know visual
style maybe bring in some kind of 80s
desks like cynthy score if you want to
and and make it about kids who who are
least counselor age and bring it back
from the sort of like ah you know
20-somethings in the would make it a
little bit more of a fleshed out world
without going like Oh telepathic
connection and destiny and [ __ ] just
make it a small town story and make
Jason a boogeyman again and also playing
up like I think it would be a cool idea
if in the camp sequence you really did
play with a few different kinds of
sexual anxiety or sexual
because like those are always there in
Jason movies and I feel like it would be
a nice thing to do especially if you
want to breathe new life to actually
make this ex means something or use it
for something use it as a somatic thing
so like you have that very uncomfortable
sex scene between Dylan and Becky like
that is one example of that you know and
I'm sure if we flesh this out there
would be more all right guys what do you
think of our how it's a work idea what's
your Friday the 13th reboot idea put it
in the comments below subscribe to the
reel reject reason to Jerry on Twitter
and Instagram social media manager media
manager of facebook.com slash Blum house
and the real rejects and shout out to
Stacie Howard from hi room to know I
talked about Tyrone too much okay Shanna
keep sending me pictures of his small
penis oh yeah
tiny tiny so readiness and trying to
imagine then one dick Oh like